a commercial transaction a sale is very
similar to a date you're sitting across
a table from somebody
hoping to close the deal i mean right
and so
uh you know let's pretend somebody goes
out on a date
it was a set up you know it was just
like
with work you know you're introduced to
somebody um
and that kid sits across the table with
with this with his date and he says uh
you know uh really rich
i've made a lot of money i'm really
successful
um know a lot of famous people
um uh i've got a beautiful house you
should
come by and check it out sometime and
i'm on tv a lot which is great because
i'm really good looking
i mean does that kid get a second date i
mean it's such a bad date it's so
obvious how badly that went
why do we think that it's any better in
business and let's look how a business
transaction goes we sit down and we say
you know we're very successful company
in fact we're
the biggest in the industry um
uh very successful i am also one of
their top
one of the top sales people one of the
top brokers you know that um
we've our corporate headquarters are
beautiful you should come over and
have a meeting there sometime you may
have seen our commercials on tv we have
an amazing ad agency and we have
beautiful tv commercials
which is great like if we thought one
sucked why do we think this is good
sure right um the irony is if you just
learn to start with why
if you actually have a purpose cause or
belief underlying your work
it makes it profoundly changes that
whole sales call yeah so that kid sits
down again and says
you know i'm the i love what i do i'm
the luckiest person alive
i get to wake up every single morning
to inspire people to do the things that
inspire them i mean it's the most
it's like i love my work yeah and the
amazing thing is i've actually been very
successful at it and i've made a lot of
money because of it
and i got to meet all these famous
people and i built a beautiful house you
should come by and see it sometimes
and i get to go on tv all the time which
is really fun because you know i'm good
looking
like you can say all the same stuff and
now it's
the the tangible proof of the philosophy
of the belief yeah but it's not the
reason you buy
people buy into the cause and so it's
the same at work
tell us what you love why do you love
this business why did you get into this
business why is it worth
the blood sweat and tears and the
uncertainty yeah and the instability
why do you keep doing it is it just to
make money because the money is good
you know by product you know like do you
and if you don't enjoy it then start
asking yourself some hard questions yeah
like why are you doing it if it's really
that difficult
if you really don't love it but to sit
down across the table from somebody and
say
you know let me tell you why i love this
business and then you can tell them all
what makes you great yeah but we don't
do that yeah we we sell sell sell sell
and we forget that relationships
whether it's a date or a a business
relationship are all built on the same
things
you